um i think everybody asked
you know the top rappers question but
give me your top five albums off the top
of your head this isn't like a cement
list just what are the five albums come
come up okay okay uh
i gotta go i gotta go
reasonable doubt okay my favorite hoe
album
i gotta go i gotta go
uh uh
we are the streets the cox album the
locks yeah
i love that album uh life after death
big
and i gotta go nice i am
i am i am i am the third album
i am i am i'm gonna tell you the story
behind that because i i get that
reaction all the time
i feel like it's either it was written
or illmatic is everyone's answer but i
am is
i am when i came out that's when i'm
understanding music
so i went back to those you know what
i'm saying that's when i'm under i'm 14.
i remember buying that album
vividly i bought that and tlc's fan mail
the same way as a kid about fan mail
yeah because it all came out at the same
time
i remember 99 i remember that and i mean
what's the fifth one man i would have to
say the fifth one is
butcher on steroids go check that out if
you never heard butcher on stairways
you'll hear that
people always ask me what's my best
album i can never pick
i heard i listened to that the other day
and i had to stop i had to be real with
myself
butcher on steroids is some of my best
best work
i'm saying that [ __ ] is up there but
you're on steroids butcher on steroids
with green lantern
yo shout out to green man